Escuchas mucho por ahí, elecciones europeas,
elecciones al Parlamento Europeo, no sé qué,
no sé cuánto,
pero al final no tienes ni idea de lo que hablan.
Pues Mira, estas herramientas,
te van a ayudar 1 poquito más
a entender la Unión Europea.
La web de las elecciones
las preguntas más frecuentes sobre las elecciones
del 9 de junio,
cómo se eligen a los diputados,
qué poderes tiene el Parlamento Europeo.
El polo of pols de político
es 1 de los 2º de referencia de información europea.
Tienen 1 guía completísima con noticias,
encuestas y gráficos
para que lo entiendas bien lo que hace Europa.
Por mí es 1 plataforma
en la que puedes ver cómo la Unión Europea
ayuda a la zona que vives,
cómo afecta en tu vida diaria
y qué está haciendo para mejorar
Europa en general.
Si tienes alguna más, déjamela en comentarios.
Esto es factous y si nos sigues sería de locos